dieses video hier möglich gemacht durch
identische max und mich zu einem mega
event eingeladen und die haben doch eine
krasse aktion vom schlage dafür könnte
er dann auf den link in der infobox
klicken und jetzt geht der block los
[Musik]
lasst mich doch breiter und damit
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen blog meine damen und herren ich
scheiße aus wie immer bevor ich euch
natürlich sofort sagen kann das heute
überhaupt abgeht und warum ich einen
blog machen und 2000 sofortig haben wir
ein neues produkt gekauft eine fünf
meter ladekabel ich schwöre auf mein
leben es ist das aller guides dass mir
gekauft habe guck mal da hinter sich
steckdose und ich kann mir liegen und
mein handy einfach laden erste rollout
ist wahrscheinlich lukas geht anderson
dein leben warum bist du denn und willen
das ihnen schon auf den beiden ja das
heißt auf den beinen ist jetzt auf dem
klo ich will sagen dass gleich das gar
nicht selbst beantworten sondern wer
einfach mal konnte man manager jan
rouven weil er hat damit so auch das
funktioniert übrigens kann dass sie mit
ihrer kamera
und das ist irgendwie was da unter der
linse
wollte man zuschauen mal eben kurz sagen
wo gehäuse daraufhin stiegen was heute
applaus ich bin voll drauf gelegt was er
ja mit seinen worten glaube ich
eigentlich sagen wollte war dass wir
nach nicht die einzige person die mit
kaum noch los angeles sondern max kommt
tatsächlich auch noch etwas und ich
wollten doch eigentlich zusammen taxi
zum flughafen nehmen habe ich mir
gestern abend schon direkt gesagt hey
ich weiß dass du direkt wieder viel
früher da sein möchte sich und naja max
gerade und taxis passt dazu kann man
nicht nach mir gerade noch brötchen war
[Musik]
vielleicht durch die lange brauchen wir
träger zum flughafen 25 minuten perfekt
hier ist einfach so ein roter teppich
auf dem weg zur security
in münchen angekommen und treffen jetzt
leider innerhofer
vollidiot es liegen jetzt mit diesem 380
und das ist echt richtig heftiges
flugzeug und dahin steht max
[Musik]
dies erklärt nennen
später sind wir jetzt in los angeles
angekommen natürlich keine einzige wolke
am himmel sitzen im auto und diese bis
zum todesfall
wir sind endlich dem hotelzimmer aber
meine damen und herren der ausblick ist
tatsächlich das erste hin ist downtown
sogar ich war auf jeden fall grad schon
direkt duschen genau so wie man es von
ihr sind alle seit ca 24 stonnen schon
war es sieht so aus als wäre das ganze
jetzt gegen die nachher von ein oder
zwei minuten passiert aber nein die
ganze sache bisher in diesem blog sind
jetzt irgendwie 23 24 stunden
cool oder schwierig was kann dieser
kamera
solche kassen haben damit machen kann
ich meine schaut euch wieder all diese
pommes und burger dann und aussehen aber
auch gegessen und max und ich sind die
ganze zeit in diesem laden land nur halb
eingeplant
jetlag gehen wir jetzt zurück ins hotel
guten morgen los angeles ach da fährt
also mein zug eigentlich wollte
frühstücken im hotel allerdings kostet
das ganze wasser und jetzt streifen wir
alle hier irgendwo am board of fame her
und das problem ist dass die läden nicht
mehr auf haben wir es nicht mehr
ich habe mir natürlich wieder den
perfekten platz ausgesucht sind einmal
werden die features kam hier teilnehmen
monate nicht gesehen aber jetzt sieht
man sieht also dass spielen vier mal
zwei spieler gegeneinander max und ich
spielen als deutschland immer schon
deutschland trikots bekommen
im gegenteil
glaube ich england spiele gegen valdez
spielt mexiko die schweren spiele denken
wir eine chance
wir haben jetzt gerade gegen england
gewonnen freunde gegen mexiko leider
verloren mexikos
ihr seht ihr jetzt auf jeden fall noch
mal ein paar highlights eingeblendet
[Musik]
wachsen ich hatte übrigens auch von
polen herkommen wir sind jetzt gerade
beim streaming haus angekommen also das
ist wirklich einfach sollen wohnungen
und rooftop mäßig da hinten ist los
angeles alles da hinten ist häuser wachs
und ich spiele jetzt gerade schon seit
zwei stunden max gerade deswegen will ja
und wenn man da in dem fenster schaut
ich hätte sie aber so
[Musik]
die stücke will ja um 7 morgen wir
befinden uns gerade auf dem weg nach
santa monica ich bin eine mehrheit aus
dem fenster nichts anderes statt es gibt
und dann gibt es hier nicht haben
wunderschön ist natürlich wieder sein
leben lang irgendwie ein pokémon spielen
und das ist gefallen bürgerladen und man
kann so einen slider trio bestellen ist
aber nicht genau was leider bedeutet und
es gibt nur ein' pons leider das für
mich eine nordamerikanische buchstaben
schmuck schildkröte
pofalla wollen eine lücke de ski im
kreis
die kapuziner fast auf jeden fall würde
das meinen konzerten was soll man machen
wir gehen jetzt mal zusammen meine
fresse ist das kalb beim rodeo drive
handel kommen da käme so posten wurden
weil sie den rodeo drive nicht kennt das
ist diese straße hier für diese ganzen
heftigen leben sind also in gta da wo
man sich diese anzüge kaufen für des
youtube channels kong kraft jetzt sind
wir hier bekommen ich habe mir die hand
nicht wegen der sonne sondern eine
pflanze fotos machen kann kämpfen ich
freunde aber wir wollen auf jeden fall
die ganze reichen menschen
beispielsweise und reiche leute oder sie
zum beispiel ist auch wahrscheinlich
richtig reich hat sie geantwortet
die sonne unfassbar lange straße hoch
gefahren weil wir einfach ein paar kilo
mehr sehen wollten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann läge noch eins machen
wir sind jetzt gerade noch mal so ein
bisschen rum gefahren und haben
herausgefunden dass eventuell kennen
könnte und zwar dass hier
da hat ja lange zeit gewohnt ist ja dann
rausgeschmissen wurde das haus wird hier
gerade wahrscheinlich irgendwie verkauft
oder so aber da hinten hatten die ja
dann im pool uns weiter und so fort also
diejenigen die früher die works von
hingeguckt haben für manja kuhl
mittlerweile finde ich nicht mehr
soldaten die das auf jeden fall alles
mal gedreht da hinten sieht man so an
der ecke geht es ist auch nach hinten
auf jeden fall sehr sehr lange und hier
steht so alles drauf so team kennen und
alles mögliche der gondel naja macht
eine ausgewogene ernährung hören wir
sind jetzt einem tagen angekommen
ich komme mir was ich so groß wie deinen
kopf alter gibt es einfach dringend
pizza chips alter wie kranke fressen
also ich glaube die schmecken nicht was
kosten voll krank oder aber wir ein
äußerst gesunde einkauf hierbei max vor
allem sprüh käse warum er spielt halt
die ganze zeit seitdem ihr hier sind
pokémon go weil er irgendwie doof finden
würde oder so und auf ab jetzt gefundene
ja schon selber welche farbe hat das
lila entscheiden also die auf jeden fall
herzlichen glückwunsch an der stelle es
ist gerade 14
ich schneide hier auf jeden fall jetzt
gerade noch ein video was hier
wahrscheinlich schon gesehen haben
natürlich habt ihr schon gesehen es kam
vor einigen tagen aber sonst würde ich
sagen gehe ich dann auch einfach direkt
schmeckt das essen
und das wird nun über zu lesen
zwischen golfplatz golfschläger kaufen
da vorne ist der deutschen freunde
nur wenige minuten später waren es
gerade beim hofladen einkaufen ich habe
auf jeden fall ein bisschen neues outfit
wird nicht gekauft max tatsächlich hat
sich auch mit etwas gekauft
davon ist auch scream das bett dann das
haustier ist marx wir sind jetzt über
100 freunde war so nett hat schon bei
uns bestellt aber wir müssen halt ich
als halbe stunde warten oder quality you
can say say dissidenten das essen ist
jetzt angekommen wir haben einen double
cheeseburger ein normaler cheeseburger
ein noch ein normalen cheeseburger ganz
ganz viele promis haben max wir haben
danke nochmal für verstellen
gut danke 29 mal einen anruf heimberger
ausland arbeitet cheeseburger ich werde
da jetzt einfach rein weiß nicht
max hat seinen grund ist ein
angefressener noch ein bisschen hat
renate muskat gefragt wie oft
deutschland eigentlich hab gesagt
hundertmal gesagt 5000 mal antreten und
war 50 mal grandiosen niederlage ich
will geist irgend nicht ganz gesund ist
innerhalb von 15 minuten halt wirklich
durch koffer habe gab es die kritik und
jetzt schon hier und diesen genau damit
hat letztes jahr hier einfach zwei
stunden gewartet
hier viele menschen ich hasse sie den
menschen einst sitz in der lounge los
angeles und die ist auf jeden fall
besser und in köln das einzige was nur
ein bisschen ab werk ist der fahrstuhl
keine aufnahme doch warum man sich darin
stand aber der war die ganze zeit dauern
auf jeden fall auf sich jetzt zum geld
weil wir innerhalb fliegen davon ist
einfach so ein baby freunde so schön
raus zu hause kein genauer
so
claudia elia kannst du foto von mir und
der allianz arena machen und jetzt hell
wie unfair wieso das denn mitten im
flughafen parken wir haben zweieinhalb
stunden
nach königsberg
das wurde jetzt oder dieser flug
allerdings auch an und ist einfach sie
minuten von uns noch weggeflogen
also eigentlich würden wir sagen wir
scheißen jetzt drauf und suchen uns
irgendwie ein zug oder 110 leihwagen
nach köln aber wir brauchen unser gepäck
und das ist die schlange die geht es
nach der ganz hinten leben können sich
nicht schöner sagen was nicht sitzt
mittlerweile an der landstraße wurden
und werden in drei stunden geht auch
unterschiede auf
wir fliegen übrigens mit
unterschiedlichen flugzeugen ein kurzes
update besitzen den sender im stunde
und ich habe gerade essen
stecken wir keine beilagen werden er
wird mir das heißt wir sehen dem
orchester mit den händen luca visa aus
ja seitdem wir jetzt seit ca 45 stunde
münchen sind und auch vier verschiedene
bühne gebucht wurden
nehmen wir jetzt einen mietwagen und ich
muss nicht lange zeigen dass sie jetzt
alle einen die schlange für die business
class und sind art hohlraum und dass sie
jetzt das servicecenter da ist alles und
hier runter bis nach ganz hinten wir
suchen uns jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
irgendein auto das irgendwie nach köln
als gefunden ein neues update von euren
zwei treffer bei kein scheiß vermieter
hat noch karten
was wir machen sollten natürlich liebe
zu uns nach köln bringen
was 1000 euro die wir jetzt gerade noch
ein bier zu haus hier in münchen und
werden jetzt von blabla mit verlängern
kann was abgeholt so dass ich so fertig
auch sehr wir sind seit 30 stunden woche
oder so
zurück in köln und erstmal richtig gut
ernähren ich bin wieder zu hause können
meine damen und herren es ist gerade 30
36 sollte eigentlich um 17 uhr landen
hier in köln
es hat jetzt alles noch so ein bisschen
länger gedauert an der stelle ganz
kurzem an ein riesiges dankeschön an die
max für mich eingeladen haben und
natürlich auch elli abgleich megacool
419 testen zu dürfen dass wir an den
play offs cup teilnehmen durften machen
ich habe leider nicht gewonnen das
finale aber auf jeden fall was echt geil
die ganze reise nur die rückreise weiß
halt ein bisschen doof mit dem flug aber
dann kann die lufthansa natürlich nichts
für sondern es war halt einfach ein
blödes unwetter bei münchen trotzdem
will ich an der stelle den blog jetzt
auf betten meine damen und herren wenn
ihr euch gefällt hat das gerne mal ein
leica wollte dass ich eventuell mehr
flagge weil ich habe da auf jeden fall
haben bock drauf an schreibt mir die
kommentare blog colada
[Musik]